les amis mes amis mes amis s'il vous
plaît mes amis mes amis le conseil
national de surveillance de l'antenne en
période électorale nous prie de
communiquer pendant toute la durée de la
campagne électorale en vue des élections
législatives des 21 et 28 mars 1993
les animateurs et les producteurs de
télévision sont tenus de veiller à ce
que soient scrupuleusement respecter les
équilibres du temps de parole et de
représentation entre les différentes
formations politiques notamment entre la
droite et la gauche
voilà alors en clair cela signifie que
si d'aventuré vous vous gratter
l'oreille droite
il faudra également pour des raisons
d'équilibré que vous vous gratier
l'oreille gauche
cette règle des amis est valable pour
l'ensemble des parties du corps pour les
messieurs par exemple si d'aventuré
l'envié vous prenait de goût du monde a
compris la saison on a compris
cet homme a décidé de prendre tous les
risques
tous les samedis soirs il va relever un
formidable défi vous tenir en haleine
pendant une heure pour vous empêcher le
zapper et conserver son hardy matt il
est prêt à tout tous les moyens sont
bons même la qualité
[Musique]
michel fugain jacques isart dont antoine
de caunes
série k le professeur
le président lorrain le chien sam et moi
xxi spontanées un petit instant puisque
vous avez fait votre entrée par la
droite je vais vous demander
conformément aux consignes du conseil
national de surveillance de bien vouloir
faire également votre entrée par la
gauche
ça ne sera pas très long le bon
équilibre et à ce bris sortait en zigzag
je vous prie pour ne avantagé personne
voilà très bien
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
chantal c'est quoi ce bordel charest qui
l'applaudît aujourd'hui c'est son boulot
d'accord mais ouais d'accord bien là
c'est quoi la
bhopal et quand le faire arrêter
d'applaudir tout est cher et la
variation avec la direction de
traduction ces trois semaines
1538 francs moi tant que j'ai pas mon
pognon d'accord avec vous
ballet je crois pas ça chantal
quand j'ai réussi
le samedi arrêtez vous
[Applaudissements]
ok vous
bon je suis très ému
[Applaudissements]
m
ces noix à thierry
[Applaudissements]
ok ok ces camps sont d'accord pour 15
cents par jour mais maintenant c'est
deux mille deux mille fois
une donnée qui résonner les faits allant
diplomate
une balancelle et bien ça c'est du
chantage ça annonce à gérer
ok d'accord et c'est ça à la télé bah
ouais thierry faut quoi aller je suis
pas chien là
[Applaudissements]
eh bien cher thierry un petit bilan
comme il est de tradition alors la
séquence qui a le mieux marché la
semaine dernière c'était la séquence la
toya jackson et ça c'était votre idée
diriez l'a vraiment en cette émission
cette idée géniale
vraiment on peut dire que vous êtes ce
qu'on appelle un magicien de la
télévision ça méritait bien ces quelques
applaudissements mais bon là cette
semaine thierry tout magicien que vous
êtes j'ai bien peur que vous ne
parveniez plus à trouver une idée du
même tonneau
détrompez-vous professeur j'ai trouvé
halo reach ex la soeur aînée de michael
jackson alors lalabé comment vous est
venue cette idée géniale tirer j'étais
au restaurant que ma femme professeur et
vous mangiez quoi sans indiscrétion à ma
femme a une grand mère qui a une soeur
aînée qui chante dans les églises et je
me suis dit sereine et chanter sereine
et chanter jackson et je suis arrivé à
rebbie jackson voici rebbie jackson
le sang
météo
[Musique]
m
alors président lorrain ça va ça va bien
ça va très bien merci
dites moi vous le la à oui oui vous
savez je ne peux jamais résisté à une
petite coupe des coupes
petit scoop pour le président laurent
louis abolie tout va très très bien et
je vous remercie mr dissoute de me
donner la parole car je vais maintenant
rappelé les trois revendications
principales de l'association nationale
des téléspectateurs français à savoir le
respect des horaires
le retour des vitrines la présence d'un
présentateur de gargar oui non je sais
je sais messieurs je radote je me régale
mais si on ne répète pas et si on aura
d'autres pas les choses n'arrivent
jamais alors que je me permets de
radoter d'accord là en revanche monsieur
ardisson maintenant je voudrais vous
adresser des remerciements chaleureux à
car la semaine dernière vous avez tenu
votre promesse et vous avez fait venir
sur ce plateau danièle gilbert mes
adhérents ont adoré les premiers ont
fait une ovation
l'avait promis pendant maintenant quand
même il ya une petite chose qui se passe
c'est que mes adhérents regarde votre
émission en masse ils sont de plus en
plus nombreux à venir toutes les
semaines nous rejoindre donc il sait
très bien que vous fassiez un petit
résumé des épisodes précédents parce que
sinon vous savez 18 ans personne qui
s'en vont comme ça c'est un peu embêtant
on va le faire
résumé des épisodes précédents
[Musique]
ça c'est thierry il est animateur sur la
télévision publique
[Musique]
oh la la sa vie est salement compliqué
car il doit sans cesse faire de
l'audience et de la qualité
ça c'est le professeur rollin
heureusement qu'il est là celui là lui
il s'y connaît en audience et en qualité
tiens lui c'est le président lorrain
thierry adore ses 18 millions de
téléspectateurs adhérents du coup il se
prend tout permis thierry reçoit ses
nombreux amis du showbiz européen et de
la jet set internationale thierry c'est
l'ami des stars et la star des amis
tiens voilà son vieux papa portiques qui
est prêt à tout pour se faire embaucher
mais thierry ne se laisse pas avoir
depuis deux semaines thierry examine les
candidates et les potiches
c'est dur de les départager elles sont
toutes si jolie et si talentueuse
thierry parviendra-t-il à sauver la vie
de zap le plus fidèle ami de l'audimat
ça dépend de vous
beaucoup d'entre vous ont été écoeurés
par le sort réservé aux chiens
d'audience philippin là bas lorsque
l'audience d'une émission chute
ils sont abattus par la chaîne est
mangée par les téléspectateurs
et ça nous a plu et ne veut pas non non
non non non non non mais sur dix on vous
n'allez pas recommencer avec ce pauvre
hasard je vous ai déjà dit que mes
adhérents regarde alors ficher vu là bas
j'ai regardé un tu veux rester en vie
basée à pune
oui oui oui oui mais tu sais mon
japonais il ya aussi des chiens
l'audience très heureux tu vas voir
billy le chien d'audience de nbc
une vraie star là-bas à monza tout nous
regarde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est un beau sujet monsieur ardisson ça
c'est un beau sujet bravo j'espère que
tout le monde va bien regarder sinon une
petite balle dans la tête
oui oui le petit à petit de tardi sont
là ce que je raconte que je vous dise de
mots pour moi manger car elle a des
émissions comme ça tout seul de ses 9
août dans la baie la télévision c'est
pas étonnant qu'on parte on briochin
non mais c'est pas vrai faux bruits
pareil mais c'est comme ça que les os x
10 dons et chaque idée en plus vous
allez laisser celle du seul tube un
droit du travail c'est moi qui devrait
l'avoir jeunes gens gardent pas dans la
tête je te le dis moi c'est vrai
quelques papes ferret c'est insulter
sans rien des très bons pour nous que
vous vous engueuler plus l'audiencement
avant et madame cher de vous savez qu'il
le faut est le chien
le fouette le chien est ce que les
chiens ça me dégoûte
j'aimerais vu l'excellent dégueu l'âge
de chiens ça pue le char comme toi ça me
choque pas que pippa bredy évident la
vieille non mais qu'est ce que c'est je
voyais surtout vouloir moi écrire dire
un truc ça pète le clan des veuves s'est
déjà club des morts tard parce que j'ai
deux buts et moi c'est moi j'ai de
petites balades dans la gueule jédir
connaît celle au connacht
non
pour moi c'est bon pour l'audience parce
qu'elle m'a pas rater la wii mais
thierry ça valait la peine d'amendé
c'est tout à fait bon pour l'audience
il faut souffrir un peu avant pour faire
de l'audience là c'est bon c'est bon
c'est très bon c'est même trop bon
thierry on est de nouveau en sueur shoah
il va falloir trouver quelque chose pour
faire redescendre un petit peu la
pression là on est sur le point
d'exploser
j'ai ce qu'il faut j'ai larmes absolue
professeurs
ouais ça lui c'est bernard lapin dis moi
j'aurais pas laisser mon stylo hier soir
chez toi hein je veux pas les vérifier
rivasi
on va voir vite maintenant alors il a
perdu son stylo il a peut-être raté à
quelqu'un
[Musique]
rien ou prêter votre stylo s'il vous
plaît
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bana
à
[Musique]
alors rendez service constant ya plus un
gramme d'audience la très bien c'est
très bien descendu thierry c'était le
but
en revanche vous avez bien fait
d'arrêter l'extrait à ce moment là parce
que j'ai eu peur que vous arriviez au
petit journal de moustiques les
nouvelles et là au contraire ça aurait
fait redécollé 1 et ce n'était pas le
but recherché mais là c'est parce l
audience et bien stable on peut
enchaîner mais attend que les choses
sont rentrées dans l'ordre voici la
séquence qui a fait le plus de dix
matches à la télévision la semaine
dernière lincendie du world trade center
non non
or
alors président lorrain vous êtes
satisfait et j'espère au fcb si vous
vous n'aurez pas la même chose dans un
peu plus pas de problème voici la même
chose on n'a plus besoin
[Musique]
quelque chose s'est bloqué choix sont
pas pareils
par exemple loisel l'oxygène
à
et d'après revenez
[Musique]
et mike légal l'aéronavale vous demande
a très bien
un mic nous pensons que la situation
dans le salon panoramique est grave
nous avons calculé qu'ils ont 17 ou 18
minutes de sursis et encore il faudrait
trois heures pour les évacuer tous avec
la bouée ces gens vont mourir si on ne
fait rien pour les secourir il y as
peut-être un dernier espoir
monsieur johnson est un ingénieur civil
va vous dire ce qu'ils proposent et
étant donné la structure de la charpente
du salon panoramique il est possible
qu'elles puissent supporter l'explosion
quelle explosion
excusez moi
en vertu des consignes qui nous sont
donnés par le comité de surveillance
pour l'équilibrage droit de go je
voudrais très rapidement rééquilibrer le
public j'ai remarqué qu'il ya trop de
monde sur la droite dont je demanderai à
5 personnes de bien vouloir émigrer
de ce côté pour se rendre là bas s'il
vous plaît et de ce côté il y a trop de
gens habillés en rouge donc si le
monsieur qui est habillé en rouge
pouvait lui changer également deux côtés
voilà l'equilibre serait conforme aux
consignes et puis mon chat président
excusez-moi de vous importuner
j'aimerais que quant à vous vous
puissiez vous asseoir au milieu et non
sur la gauche du canapé rouge bien sûr
excusez moi bravo proviseur vous êtes le
st juste de l'equilibre électorale c'est
mon devoir donc cher président l'a bien
thierry les choses sont en ordre
c'est quand vous voulez merci professeur
mesdames messieurs voici maintenant le
casting de thé les petits jeux qui tient
toute la france en haleine ce qu'estime
arrive désormais à sa phase terminale
rappelez vous il ya encore quinze jours
elles étaient 24 jeunes et jolies
candidates
aujourd'hui après une sélection
impitoyable
elles ne sont plus que 5 toujours jeune
et jolie et à l'issue de la terrible
épreuve de ce soir une seule d'entre
elles sera notre télé petit hardy matt
des dames messieurs elles vont avoir une
minute pour séduire la france mais
pendant que notre première finaliste se
concentre toujours à en profiter pour
faire découvrir un duo absolument
exceptionnel des chanteurs qui font
revivre les riches heures de la motown
et ses étoiles blacks
voici
qu'est-ce que vous lancez la tuerie
tchané dix professeurs un truc génial
qu'est ce que c'est que ça c'est génial
c'est que j'ai retiré du marvin gaye
c'est énorme c'est possible partagé la
le sous les yeux la liste du top 5 en
bois ne voit pas figurer votre char
d'hindi dedans enfin un professeur
simple est vachement j'adore j'écoute
série matin dès votre rôle c'est de
faire de l'audimat c'est pas d'exprimer
vos goûts personnels sais je sais mais
bon je sais pas moi je trouve ça génial
voulait pas l'écouter écouter thierry
pas celle ci vous voulez mais à vos
risques et périls que l'accord est celle
face à un point d'accord je vais passer
à mes risques et périls d'accord voici
china daily
[Musique]
non
m
[Musique]
mais ma tête
et ne sais pas
oh
là
[Musique]
oh
ap
com
alors
c'est dans son aventure c'est dense
abbaoui jerry sept ans maintenant si
vous voulez venir jeter un oeil sur la
courbe d'audience
on est au plus bas voilà un bon bah oui
je ferai plus cette dernière fois que je
mets un truc qui me plaît c'est la
dernière fois nous laisser aller comme
un imbécile à l'anr fois que j'avais
exprimé vos goûts personnels bon parce
que là c'est parce que ce qu'on peut
faire
peut-être faudrait-il donner un petit
coup de coluche j'aimerais maintenant
remercie la chaîne vous offrir quelques
secondes de coluche voici la séquence
autopano de la semaine voici comique
mort dans un film culte
[Applaudissements]
notre bon casting de thé les petits
[Musique]
non mais non motivation sylvie grande
grande je veux être une grande grande
grande potiche jeu la vocation
tu connais la règle du jeu tu sais que
tu as une minute pour séduire la france
je rappelle la règle du jeu la petit la
france la france
la potiche vas-y bonjour je m'appelle si
les sévices lgi bon bah j'ai rien
préparé en fait donc je sais pas je suis
très difficilement
je suis très intimidé en fait très très
intimidée vous avez vraiment les
français comme ça c'est un peu mais bon
j'avais pensé à faire plein plein de
petites choses chante et je connais
cette chanson my linh awalé bien la nabe
ritchie
bref mais bon et je vais penser aussi à
danser
j'avais pas trop du truc 70 j'avais pas
mais bon j'ai préféré vous parlez en
vous regardant bien droit dans les yeux
voilà je peux faire des clins d'oeil je
vous en fais pas mal très bien on
l'applaudît s'est pas trop mal passé
au weser il faut demander à sylvie est
ce que vous avez bien senti la france au
fond de vous même
est ce que vous avez senti les parfums
de la corrèze du berry du jura il avait
senti en mode la faune très bien vous
avez tous bien senties nous avait senti
le roussillon d'ailleurs je n'engagerai
pas après j'aime bien j'inscris tirer
une petite cigarette président écoutez
moi alors là je suis au comble du
bonheur la france a beaucoup de chance
de l'avoir dans les yeux mais moi c'est
pas mal non plus puisque jeudi en
guadeloupe
sacré président toujours le mot pour
rire merci et représente 18 millions
d'adhérents donc et c'est toujours le
rire pour rire bon bah merci beaucoup
merci s'il dessine oui merci
et nous passons maintenant à notre télé
potiche suivant dans la bleue
[Musique]
non
vraiment motivation snapap oui
j'aimerais devenir petit sur hardy matt
il ya des chances et pour moi potiche
n'essaie plus et peut-être péjoratif
mais pour moi ça aussi des côtés
positifs bien sûr puisque une petit doit
être sensuelle sexy elle doit faire
plaisir au public
oh c'est un très très bon début ma
petite valérie tu connais la règle du
jeu
1la petit la france la france la petite
tu as une minute pour séduire la france
top chrono moi j'aime tout ce qui a
trait à la forge qui à la santé et au
genre humain
[Musique]
alors prendre des cuites d'enfer oui oui
oh lalala lalala dévoiler les faits
alors se rencontrer quelques exemples
c'est tout simplement il faut bien ça
sur votre escalier sur une planche que
vous auriez préalablement bien nettoyer
atteindre pas vous faire de mal
il vous fait de huit banques soient
élégant c'est peut-être une virée pour
les hommes pour la troisième nuit ce
qu'on aime toujours être dans les bras
de muscles et bien entendu vous pourriez
vous le samedi
j'adore le sport c'est marrant je suis
tout de suite là le maître store ce
qu'il a dit et n'a qu'à bien se tenir
évasif quant à corrèze corrèze
c'est sympa c'est comme ça et de montrer
des mouvements très bien parti bien sûr
pour sophie favier non professeurs et
bien écoutez je pense que le retour de
davina fera plaisir à notre ami
président laurent oui oui oui absolument
ça faisait longtemps qu'on avait pas vu
davina ou sa petite soeur et en plus ce
professeur là il faut remarquer mission
les clips droite gauche est bien
respectée très bien respectée on
applaudit
c'est beaucoup
merci
[Applaudissements]
non
un très très bientôt
m
monsieur
[Applaudissements]
il est nommé sur la première partie du
casting de télé potiche est terminée
nous en aurons trois autres tout à
l'heure on applaudit les deux premières
[Applaudissements]
c'est votre écoute et elles sont toutes
plus charmantes les unes que les autres
elle me rappelle ces merveilleuses
femme-tronc que nous avons
malheureusement perdu qui étaient les
speakerines et à ce propos là monsieur
ardisson vous étiez engagé la semaine
dernière à faire des recherches afin de
nous retrouver cette charmante
speakerine de couleurs que gillett a
aujourd hui emploi président je m'y
emploie mais c'est pas facile il ya dix
ans il faut mettre plus de monde je ne
sais pas il faut un peu se presser car
n'oubliez pas 18 millions personnes qui
sur tf1 que je crois que j'ai trouvé
quelqu'un que vous préférerez encore ah
bon ouais quelqu'un de beaucoup plus
connu que gillett a au plus connus - là
messieurs voici antoine de caunes
l'émission ans espace comment nulle part
ailleurs je suis un peu fatigué mais là
je suis dans un état grippal et j'ai un
boulot monstre je fais sans personnages
et l'ennui c'est que je suis payé comme
un seul individu c'est à dire qu'il ya
une exploitation de lemont métier qui me
choque un petit peu oui c'est bien
comment ces idées de personnages ses
déguisements
je regarde tous les gens négligent et
qui sont autour de moi et j'essaie de
les imiter un petit peu ce n'est pas
compliqué je vais changer dans le milieu
télévision je n'ai que l'embarras du
choix avec gildas c'est le grand amour
ou c'est un faux jeu les connu tout
petit ouais mais pour moi c'est il est
resté toujours sur le petit homme que
j'ai connu oui prévenus âgés en mai un
géant du rire à faire du dimanche 27 à
l'idée d'avoir un papa qui bossaient la
télé non oui et non ça m'a aidé sur le
plan de l'écriture par exemple j'ai créé
des polars et comme tu sais mon père
était membre des french polar expedition
alors mon plat j'ai eu le pied à
l'étrier tout de suite ça m'a aidé sur
le plan journalistique je travaille dans
un journal qu'ils appellent le vélo le
vélo la confondre avec le pédalo qui est
beaucoup plus spécialisée et ça m'a aidé
sur mon comportement et mon ironie
vis-à-vis des hommes qui l'entourent
mais tu fais de la radio aussi oui feda
radio j'ai toujours appuyé d'eau qui
fonctionne en angleterre je lance une
émission avec jean paul gaultier le
fameux couturier celui qui habille eelv
est en mer a fait cette robe tricolore
chaque fois de plus à ses yeux on
entendait la marseillaise et puis qui
habite aussi une femme qui n'arrête pas
de se déshabiller qui s'appelle madonna
avait 13 ans lui avec madonna parce que
quand on lui demande de présenter son
dernier modèle allemand de ses fesses et
madonna cimade alors vous êtes contents
vous l'avez votre vedette de la télé de
la semaine
vraiment je suis je suis je suis très
très content monsieur ardisson mai mais
comme vous l'avez merveilleusement fait
est fait remarquer antoine de caunes a
eu un papa extraordinaire il a toujours
un papa qui a été un des grands grands
grands hommes de thierry c'est vraiment
je dirais si vous permettez antoine
merci antoine et mais aussi vivant toile
et surtout vive georges de côte-d'or je
connais
non
monsieur mardi son pendant que nous
sommes dans les grands hommes de télé
j'ai un petit service à vous demander
j'ai eu au téléphone il ya assez peu de
temps monsieur mougeotte qui m'a promis
comme à tous un retour prochain en mars
avec un concept de patrick sabatier et
monsieur ardisson nous n'avons aucune
nouvelle de patrick sabatier
alors pensez à à ses millions dans la
nouvelle de patrick sabatier nous on en
a vous en avez mais bien sûr il va très
bien il va très bien et vous le dit lui
même regarder ça tient c'est une eau
pétillante et savoureuse une eau pour
ceux qui visent plus fort
[Musique]
c'est à patrick ça va fort seniors ça va
fort très fort mesdames messieurs je
dois vous avouer quelque chose ce qui
aujourd'hui fait un tabac dans les
émissions ce qui enthousiasme et
téléspectateurs en un mot ce qui fait de
l'audience
ce sont les fameux incident de plateau
vous savez ces accrochages entre invité
ses bagarres c'est un sulky dégénère
tout ça c'est un cadeau du ciel pour nos
gens de télé thierry justement rï à ce
profond il ya un incident qui a eu lieu
à s'est récemment entre bruno masure
nagui et serrault au journal est ce
qu'on pourrait revoir cet extrait il
avait été beaucoup d'audimat dressé le
top c'est à al-ayyat il ya un
présentateur célèbre il ya un acteur
célèbre
il ya un animateur ses lèvres bravo
france 2 on regarde
merci beaucoup mais bruno je voulais
vraiment comme à chaque manche a dormi
chez selon michel mercier coup parce que
j'ai touché ses seins professionnels de
première c'est la face et choco bref
vous avez fait là tout à l'heure c'était
à mon avis pas admissible oui bon c'est
le foot quand je n'ai rien lâché pour la
paix est non mais c'est moi qui voulais
vous donne en fait je ne sais pas je
voulais que jouer des barrages de vaud
peng et non merci
comme je sais qu'il faut pas dépasser
les 1000 francs ou un non mais on
déborde beaucoup voilà c'est 999
remparts je sais pas si on peut le oui
oui ça franchement je suis un père merci
oui voila merci de vos cadeaux il faut
rendre en alaska une émission ce soir il
faut pas qu'on déborde dans un arrêt
quart d'heure je savais pas qu'on fait
payer ont fait penser genre de réflexion
d'ensemble garde
et bien margés c'est l'histoire de deux
anciennes vedettes de la télévision
reconverti justement dans l'escroquerie
décidément je rappelle 22h30 taratata
avec donc [ __ ] vers 23h45 et non je ne
peux pas le dire dernier journal en
compagnie de rémi roche demain à 7h50
gérard leclerc recevra à mon confrère
alain duhamel qui parlera de son dernier
livre les peurs française
après le paris dakar et le journal des
courses la nette de la météo de ne
payerez ouais elle va être content
d'avoir deux boselli dans ce journal
nathalie qui vous parlera d'un sérieux
renforcements des vols partant le quart
nord-ouest du pays à demain matters
merci beaucoup pour ce soir thierry et
bien maintenant que nous venons de voir
cet extrait puisqu'il a fait beaucoup de
dymat que nous notre but c'est de faire
également beaucoup de dix matchs vous
propose tout simplement que nous jouions
ce petit sketch
vous avez le texte sont les feuilles que
je vous ai fait donner tout à l'heure
alors si le président lorrain veux bien
jouer le rôle de nagui ou même thierry
vous joueriez le rôle de bruno masure
très vrai moi même celui de michel
serrault lorsque nous allons faire
décoller l'audimat et bien résidence et
quant à moi de démence et oui c'est vrai
non mais bruno bruno je voudrais
vraiment mais vraiment non mais
rapidement alors non mais vraiment
j'adore michel serrault j'ai une
véritable admiration pour michel
serrault et je voudrais non mais
permettez tout à l'heure je pense que
vous êtes allé un peu loin et que vous
avez été grossier avec monsieur du tout
du tout
masure que je ne connais pas mais que
j'admire beaucoup parce que je le vois
souvent dans ce journal et c'est un
professionnel de première classe
ce que vous avez fait là dans ce journal
est à mon avis pas admissible alors je
vais l'embrasser pour la peine
nan mais c'est moi qui voulais vous
embrasser pour m'excuser non mes excuses
et le parce que c'est un jeune il est
pas mal un jeu trouvera pas sa demande
pas du tout
pardon bruno pardon votre réflexion me
réchauffe le voulez vous que je vous
débarrasse de vos papiers
non non merci beaucoup ça va je ne sais
pas comment vous remercier alors je vous
ai fait un petit chèque comme je sais
qu'il ne faut pas dépasser 1000 francs
non mais on déborde beaucoup la voilà
c'est 999 francs
c'est parfait je ne sais pas si oui oui
oui
- j'ai juste à peine y tenez ça peut
être
merci merci beaucoup merci beaucoup
merci de vos cadeaux à l'an passé
toujours plaisir président jeunes dès
que l'on parle pourtant ils ont fait
tellement de points avec ça les comprend
pas il faut rendre l'antenne à l'heure
parce qu'il ya mon émission ses soirées
il faut pas qu'on déborde dans un petit
quart d'heure je savais pas qu'il
fallait payer alors je vais donner ce
que je peux dans un petit quart d'heure
vent de panique avec caroline cellier et
bernard giraudeau c'est l'histoire de
deux anciennes vedettes de la télé qui
deviennent faussaires je rappelle qu'à
22h30 c'est taratata avec donc nagui
vers 23h45
non je peux pas lire le dernier journal
avec rémy roche couvrez-vous c'est pas
chauffer chez vous il chauffe jamais ici
à aa
c'est pas quel est leur secret mais pour
nous c'est un flop les places le temps
et nous ça marche pas quand on le fait à
la lettre nous avons dit le petit
frémissement mais enfin - signifiant
tralala quel est leur secret professeurs
je ne sais pas je pense que ce sont de
grosses stars surmédiatisé hyper
matraquer alors évidemment dès qu'ils
ouvrent la route variable comprenez
c'est comme si on enlevait leur pantalon
voilà oui je crois va tuer
mais monsieur verdict par exemple j'ai
une idée si on mettait des chanteurs si
je connais bien les téléspectateurs
là si on met des chanteurs ça va il a
déjà fait les chanteurs ou alors des des
femmes des chanteurs la fédé semaine
dernière et des femmes d enfants de
femmes de chanteur ouais d enfants de
femmes de chanteur oui oui mais alors là
thierry excusez moi
tant qu'à faire de l'enfant de femmes de
chanteur fait donc de l'enfant de femmes
de chanteurs morts
les chiffres prouvent que l'enfant de
femme du chanteur mort fait six fois
plus d'audience que le réforme de
l'infâme de face et bien ça c'est bien
ça c'est bien
enfants deux femmes deux chanteurs morts
rien
[Musique]
il ya pire
qt
tous
vva
le bo
[Musique]
ici
c
chut
je ne sais pas
jeter
[Musique]
m
cherry a une petite erreur sans gravité
dans votre série enfants de femmes de
chanteurs morts
jordi jordi n'est pas un enfant chéri
c'est une marchandise
oui un jour dit n'a pas de parent en
séries il ya des producteurs tombera
professeur suis désolé c'est pas grave
excusez moi
voici maintenant notre deuxième invité
princess erika
[Musique]
oui t'as vu c'est très chaud ici hein
d'autant plus que nous on est très
content de te recevoir
tu es contente parce qu'en fait on pense
si tu veux que c'est toi qui aurait dû
avoir la victoire en victoire la musique
la victoire de révélation féminine de
l'année
[Applaudissements]
tous on était tous ici un petit peu
déçue de devoir saisi qu'il l'avait ya
une chose quelque chose qui est certaine
c'est que zazie ne mettra jamais les
pieds si jamais c'est une question de
principe c'est nous on est un
elle est sympa mais elle chante pas mal
mais nous on préfère princess erika
elle ne viendra jamais eh bien on va
regarder tout de suite à l'extrait de
ton clip qallali toujours tout parent
à voir sa professeur karl et en histoire
et vit dans l'illusion m'a pas donné moi
si on se pose pas question car tous les
bambins
fortement appréciée
il doit re
n'est ce pas le vendre
[Musique]
chercher des raisons souvent
moi demain
et les bonnes sur les chantiers
aujourd'hui sa part
mais
[Musique]
alors princess erika je vais te faire
une interview à la drucker
mais bien sûr mais aussi je les aime
beaucoup et très inspiré par lui le
parcours que tu effectues dans la
chanson est vraiment formidable
comment vis-tu ses succès qui est qui
est très méritée ah ouais bah je le vis
très bien
attendez mon dieu je le vis bien c'est
vrai que je suis beaucoup reconnu dans
la rue j'arrête pas de saison comptera
sur le temps long roman si tu veux c'est
le revers de la médaille alors passer
ces pertes sont vieux je suis gentil
princess erika tu es belle tu es
intelligent tu possède une voix
magnifique tu as un sens du rythme
merveilleux at on fait découvrir
prochainement sur scène est ce qu'on
aura ce ce bonheur
j'ai fait pas mal de saint louis merten
première partie dira-t-on les [ __ ]
vertes
qu'est ce qu'il m'a fait ces fiches et
j'ai fait un geste en fin mais c'est
vrai que prochainement on va me re
découvre sur une grosse centaine
d'heures c'est vrai que sa princesse
erika ont dit à juste titre que tu es
une artiste qui travaille beaucoup
donnent vraiment à fond dans toutes tes
chansons c'est complètement sa toile
quelqu'un de très très très peu changé
et c'est vrai que c'est une chanson
c'est tellement c'est un peu
autobiographique elle s'en excuse moi
chantal c'est quoi ce micro de merde
qu'on voit sans arrêt dans le champ
s'est réjoui par cortyl au score
bon c'est pas lui c'est à lui qu'est ce
que les quotes parts et on écoute
princess erika quand le tout connu avec
30 de blabla
[Applaudissements]
je te garantis que sont le score je
m'étais bétonner un tu peux y aller je
te le disais plus le score est là qu est
ce qu on écoute tu vois là je suis
traquer ces fonds patron c'était disait
fort parce que vraiment mais moi je ne
me suis pas reconnu
c'était difficile qui a rien pour toi
c'était un mec qui me balance dans
l'émission quoi jacques au foie mais non
mais tu te fais piéger comme un bluff
mais là temps c'était vachement bien
trouver quand même qu est-ce qu on
écoute un vrai parce que bon le scorff
j'ai bossé k way
moi je me sentais avec les copains y a
rien sur les sports je disais rien ont
pu continuer c'est qu'est-ce qu'on
écoute parti tu t'es fait planter away
trop devenir un bonne chance quand même
saluer
j'espère que tu nous on le voit pas trop
pour cet incident et la paix non
artistes comme toi vas voir le coeur
grande princesse com - ouais ouais bon
est ce que tu veux nous chanter quelque
chose parce que je crois que j'ai pas à
me semble que j'ai remarquée était
désigné avec ma guitare on a où il
aurait aussi des trucs un peu comme
s'est improvisé allez c'est pas préparé
tu va nous chanter ton prochain single
c'est bon c'est pas préparé mais c'est
le prochain single
quand t'écoutes princesse à des rythmes
et mon nom je ne me l'ait fait mal et
emportées par les flots et la tête m'a
cassé
je baisse la tête quand vient la tempête
quand tu es cgt les votes
à la mairie ou au non je ne me
laisserais mal et emportées par les
flots et la peine ma carrière
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup c'est vrai qu'au demandé
de sortir par la droite parce que corti
est sorti par la gauche et comme il est
en période électorale on essaye
d'équilibrer un tu peux passer par là
voilà merci beaucoup
voilà
notre casting de thé les potiches suite
[Musique]
non evra vrai nom stefani ce motivation
je vais te tapes otish thierry je voyais
des chances tu sais tout peut arriver ce
soir ils font entre nous tu connais la
règle du jeu
tu as une minute pour séduire la france
oui 1 la france la swedish la potiche la
france est prête
oui vas-y méfie
[Musique]
je suis
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pau
[Applaudissements]
la pression c'est un peu un coup mignot
n'est pas un petit peu parce que c'est
mon ventre se retrouver là avec tout le
monde est avec toi avec moi en face à
thierry stéphanie ayant les yeux un
petit peu [ __ ] sa prestation a beaucoup
plu au pays du soleil levant c'est à
dire en alsace et franche-comté
président bah écoutez comme disait un
ami un cousin qui était bûcheron dans
les cévennes
elle envoie le bois de fortes chances
d'y arriver notre ami stéphane lalart
bravo
[Applaudissements]
mon enfant est l'entente mais c'est
notre télé petit suivante
nom prénom motivation hélène de moi mig
motivation faut que je me case à ces
impératifs une fois je me casse
j'ai tombé sur moi ah bah oui on va voir
on va voir tu connais la règle du jeu
j'ai deux minutes pour séduire la france
tu es prête en avant mais pour qu'il me
regarde pas il me regarde jamais
pourquoi une me regarde je me tais si
vous voulez vous absolument vous caser
une fois sur dix ça marche
alors il faut absolument qu'ils ne
regardent pas essayer pourquoi j'ai pas
de sens où on l'entend mais j'ai compris
ça y est j'ai compris mais non il attend
femme anna c'est évident il attend sa
nana voilà pourquoi il me regarde pas
l'humeur de merde moi il faut que je me
case comprenez il faut que je me casse
je vois que tu les as toiture itway
j'atterris vite elle dit
maintenant je suis marié père de famille
mais quand on fait de la cuite essayé on
a essayé de suite le de beauregard n'a
pas un pour moi mais si moi pour que je
me casse est juste un oui
[Musique]
alors des impressions cette caméra
je suis très content parce qu'il faut
absolument jouer case et donc c'est un
appel voilà donc j'ai impressionné mais
assez content on fait cela bien thierry
j'ai reconnu dans le texte d'hélène dans
le texte de ce monologue un peu de
racines légèrement matinée de corneille
ça fait très plaisir la france cultive
et le centre faire président je ne sais
pas si elle veut se caser mais moi je
suis prêt à me casser avec elle
18 millions d'adhérents nam locaux
d'humour j'espère que vous serez
bonjour
professeur elle est pas mal galéré
l'europe propos retirés faute faute
faute faute golez eh ben ça ça va vous
coûter un petit morceau nos rentes de
données inter culturel sur venise
notation
dix sept districts gol et gol et gol et
gol et quarante et une secondes de
venise d'ahmed aussi fleuri que parfumer
les palets reprennent leurs fiers
démarche
yvan de la beauté de leur propre image
qui se reflète depuis des siècles dans
le frémissement du canal un frémissement
que seul claude monet son cheval est
planté sur un quai moussu saura saisir à
la pointe de son pinceau magique je vous
dise moi je m'en branle devenu l'espace
je m'envole branle 13 secondes je
m'endors je m'envole
[Musique]
voix
et maintenant voici notre dernière télé
petit
non tu es long motivation emmanuel
jambes je veux être télé potiche dans
cette émission dans cette émission à
leurs émissions pour être encore plus
célèbre que agnès laurence et sophie en
même temps très bien mademoiselle
connaît bien la concurrence c'est bien
est ce que tu sais que tu es dans la
dernière ligne droite j'ai fait quoi
dernière ligne droite j'ai un petit
problème des kilos même déquilibre tu
vas essayer de pas être trop bouche très
bien s'y tient une minute pour séduire
la france tu connais la règle du jeu
1 la télé potiche la france la france la
télé potiche vas-y c'est à toi
[Musique]
oh
ici
[Applaudissements]
bombay
[Musique]
ça
tunisie jamais
m
arrêtez tout alors on ne refait pas non
je peux pas je peux pas comment c'était
la france au fond des yeux bon
professeur très bon dans le sud tirer le
sera si la torride torre président c'est
pas si elle a bien vu la france dans les
yeux mais alors tu sais pas si elle a du
cognac parce que j'ai ma maman un peu
n'ya que je voudrais ne pas saluer je ne
suis pas là je ne suis pas là on pourra
bien tu sais que tu a de fortes chances
de l'emporter puissiez bien aller
va-t-on vita oui revient bateau revient
[Applaudissements]
vois bien un abattement
très bien car il nous avons eu notre
dose d'érotisme grâce aux potiche
maintenant pour renforcer un petit peu
notre audience il nous faudra une petite
dose de violence pas de problème voici
maintenant le top de la violence de la
violence qui engendre et de la violence
un homme à terre sans défense
l'acharnement est impitoyable
mais ils sont cinq à frapper tous les
coups sont permis cinq hommes
cinq policiers ils sont blancs et la
victime et noir
[Musique]
dimanche soir un contrôle routier et ses
policiers se transforment en justiciers
ce soir-là il croit pouvoir agir en
toute impunité
mais un témoin non loin de là filmé la
scène
alors vous l'avez votre violence être
content oui mais non tu ris parce que ça
c'est de la violence à 5000 ou 10000
kilomètres d'ici non ce qu'il faudrait
c'est de la violence plus près d'ici
j'ai ce qu'il vous faut professeur prix
voici de la violence bien de chez nous
tout s'était passé dans le calme
jusque-là un feu allumé devant la sous
préfecture a provoqué l'apparition des
forces de l'ordre dès lors une centaine
de manifestants jeunes pour la plupart
s'en est pris aux crs durant deux heures
aux abords de la sous-préfecture les
tirs de grenades lacrymogènes ont
répondu projet de pierre bilan des
échauffourées quatre blessés légers
parmi les forces de l'ordre et
l'habituel cortège de mobilier urbain
cassé alors
bah oui mais non thierry parce que ça
c'est de la vieille violence nous ce qui
nous avons pour l'audience et de la
violence ici et maintenant de la vraie
violence nom d'une pipe
j'ai un truc tonio de la bonne vraie
grosse violent aller voir professeur la
vraie violence en direct comme à la télé
à
allez ça ça va marcher sa future épouse
le dit max allemande pâtit pas de la
demande est valide pas que ça monte pas
là et vous savez pas vous y prendre là
vous êtes gentil comme tout avec lui
la professeure je peux le brûlé avec une
cigarette
non ça va aller comme ça mais c'est
comme ça ça ira ouais bah allez voir si
ça monte tiens on va voir tout de suite
et peut-on et pas excellents scores
remercie tous dûment petit nid nobel
allait bien mais non c'est rien série à
antonio c'était pour la télé il a eu
peur le cd pour faire monter l'audience
vrai bon moral
ab oui on voit sur l'impact de votre
coup de pied dans les parties formidable
assez salat et les professeurs la bonne
violence ça marche toujours
non me faire de son vin quoi vraiment la
chasse et la coupe est pleine comme trop
de violence penser que dire que c'est ça
qui marche mais oui mais il ya peut-être
des enfants encore devant la télévision
rappelez vous la belle époque de le rtf
quand on faisait encore de belles
émissions pour les enfants ça ça ce que
je vais vous chanter c'est un très bel
hymne et heureusement ils passent encore
sur canal j colargol c'est moi qui suis
colargol l'ours qui chante enfants solo
lando qu'elles sont mi bémol en chine et
en faux col bleu roi des oiseaux
vous le savez mes amis m'a offert un
sifflet pour faire reculer
c'est moi qui suis colargol l'ours qui
chante en seul entretien sur nivelle en
guinée
encore
[Applaudissements]
oui et bien le pauvre laura je vous
rappelle quand même qu'il représente 18
millions de téléspectateurs de service
on ne l'oublié pas d'accord parce que
sinon contrairement à ce que beaucoup de
gens croient ce qui tue la télé du
samedi soir ce n'est pas le sexe à la
maison c'est le frigo oui qui rit les
gens ont un petit creux ils quittent
leur écran de télévision ils vont au
frigo à chercher un bide encore et mois
contre le frigo gels arme absolue
regardez
non
[Applaudissements]
je fais ma sortie pour voir comment ça
vous fait me votre sortie qu'elle sortit
bas mazor dirait vers quoi quelle sortie
rivière kwaï celles qu'elles sont le
conducteur de l'émission 26
thierry fait sa sortie rivière kwaï
professeur enfin un oui d'accord alors
sorti rivière kwaï sortir il va sortir
et dire que l'addition boisson vous
m'aviez promis que je pouvais venir avec
vous pour l'autographe ma petite nièce
ok venez avec vos 18 millions
d'adhérents a mis ses marques et
d'ailleurs le président lorrain fait sa
sortie rivière kwaï aux lectures et hop
[Musique]
et
18 millions c'est mignon
attention vers le ch et messieurs dans
un instant ça va commencer
installez vous dans votre faute et bien
gentiment plein plein plein cinq a320
partait tous les projecteurs vont saluer
et tous les acteurs vont s'animer rambin
beau temps
me loiseau
sa vie d'air pur est d'offrir un oiseau
d'un peu de chasse et de pêche à
l'oiseau mais jamais rien ne l'empêchent
loiseau
dans les p o
ça c'était la chanson diva poste c'est
un beau roman c'est une belle histoire
c'est une roman
en ce beau jour d'hui d'aujourd'hui ils
se sont trouvés là où dans le brouillard
c'était peut-être un jour de chance on
un cadeau de la providence c'est la fête
l'a fait
2 c'est comme à grands coups de soleil
un vent de folie pas papa en rien n'est
plus pareil aujourd'hui ta ta ta ta ta
ta tante
on a le coeur examiné par la liberté et
la liberté c'est la fête
est la refait
[Applaudissements]
sugar sugar salut bravo comment tu vas
thierry la géniale et toi comment tu te
sens tu me prends comme ça je te prends
la parole
triumph l'abri car un jeu sont contents
les gens je te laisse faire vingt
d'entre elles sont très content non
s'est régalé mais c'est bon c'est clair
on a vu toutes les dernières chansons là
on va venir te voir sa vraie bonne
écoute on s'amuse beaucoup
c'est la deuxième je passais un deuxième
soir le nokia et on rentre là pardon on
rentre on sait la deuxième soir à
l'olympia
notre quatrième ont tous et régale déjà
tout prévu tout prévu les soldats siens
alors comment tu te sens en sortant de
scène sens très bien
hu est très bien payé je veux dire quand
je dis paient c'est à dire ça veut dire
que on est nourri par les bravo
l'énergie
tu donnes de l'énergie sur une scène et
puis entre charge c'est génial les
marionnettes qui sont rechargées par le
public était fatigué quand je suis pas
fatigué
j'ai le temps de te fatiguer c'est pour
plus tard moi je viens pas emmerdés là
parce que j'ai j'avais des filles je
vais préparer plein de questions puis je
les ai oubliés dans l'espace là les
quelques questions que je pose soit pour
emmerder
ça devrait plutôt quelle question j'ai
pas envie que tu me poses invasive c'est
le secret de longévité
comment ça se fait que tu veux tu
chantes encore au tournage parce que
lorsque j'ai été servi pendant ces
quelques temps les mecs ils sont étonnés
qui a 50 verges en plus encore chanter
vouloir faire de la scène comment leur
expliquer que saltimbanques c'est un
diktat tout à fait tranquille qu'est ce
que tu veux que je te le demande alors
j'ai pas je veux pas qu'on parle
politique
subban on va pas parler poli non je n'ai
pas obligé non j'aurais plutôt envie
compte devise gaiement joyeusement de
rien de tout je prends avec très
compliqué ouais
qu'est ce que je pourrais te demander si
rudement moi n'importe quoi elle va me
demande moi l'une les pires tu peux tu
as certainement non posées débine hors
jeu mais non j'ai oublié mes filles
j'avais des questions terrible sur mes
filles je les perdais dans le derrière
les fiches en général non non non ben
lanta dupont parce qu'il ya plein de
mecs avant toi qui sont tombés sur un
ardisson qu'avec ses fils puis
l'algérien tu t'en sors bien passé
question pourri sur le monde moi demande
- ou ce que j'aime ce que j'aime ce que
j'aime pas je laurent et la wii
président lorrain aussi le président
lorrain il représente une association de
18 millions de ça fait un président je
veux dire nous on aime
non là on était le pays des présidents
vice-présidents ça du tout président est
ce que voulaient détruire quelque chose
de rien du tout moi [ __ ] ça me fait
plaisir je suis président en originalité
c'est ça j'amènerai à vous demander pour
ma petite nièce
alice est là là je n'ai pas pu vous
connaître avant mai
maintenant il est contente que vous
soyez là donc engrais lakanal à 11
elle a 11 ans elle a 11 ans b coûtera
spc quant au togo pleuvoir j'ai crij
écrit bonjour j'écris j'écris des bises
quand c'est les filles des saluts quand
c'est des mecs là je puis bonjour alice
et puis la bise d'être content président
très très très ce je vous enverrai vous
en verrez vos adhérents à l'olympia je
vais envoyer mes 18 millions d'adhérents
trois semaines mais pour trois ans elle
en avait au moins pour trois résidents
si vous deviez enchanté une ce serait
laquelle
je sais pas vous mais les hybrides ont
écouté tout par coeur je mets ça dans la
voiture j'adore moi qui ne suis qu'un
tout petit grain de sable
il m'arrive d'imaginer je suis grand que
je suis capable d'être formidable
d'avancer à pas de géant mais si je lève
les yeux je n'y peux dire ce que tu dis
je suis infiniment petit canada je ne
suis qu'un passant accrochée à la vie à
ma vie comme a eu un intérêt dans
l'infiniment mambé bravo j'ai failli le
chantier avec ouh là ça m'a très
contents allez salut président alors
donc merci monsieur ardisson jeu on est
bien d'accord
les adhérents regarde ordinaire garde a
dit matt hill ne zapperont plus et nous
la france et le chili sera sauvé le
chien sera sauvé merci monsieur
raidissement à la semaine prochaine au
revoir au revoir mois ci la vega merci
pour alice et pour la corse et pour moi
au revoir un peu président un peu
président est sympa j'ai beaucoup
d'adhérents pour être laissé un retourné
au studio parce qu'ils nous attendent la
basse et chant ty est devenu mature
salut tout le monde pas ouais et puis on
va venir voir le spectacle en entier
cette fois non pas les 5 dernières
chansons absolument bien
bon qu'est ce tu veux que je te pose
comme question pour iran de queiroz la
pause l'attend là forcément une pourri
qui traîne qu'est ce tu prends pour
tenir le coup ah oui ça c'est dans la
série du tout vraiment et ça là tu vois
il s'est dit que ça serait prête non ça
je n'ai pas encore pris à partie bon
normalement et je n'ai pas encore pris
ouais et normalement je devrais en
prendre deux demain matin prescription
de ma soeur wendy autres dons qui m'a
dit si tu veux être bien demain soir et
demain soir c'est la mondaine à césar
donc je
je prends de ça je sais pas en général
ce que je pense et de l'aspirine
c'est tout ouais puisque c'est un anti
inflammatoire et ça me suffit amplement
bon et puis donc j'ai besoin de rien
j'ai dû tomber dedans quand j'étais
petit bon et ben tu vois ça s'est bien
passé finalement
allez merci geof haut niveau tu refais
le chemin de l'emploi
oui je te laisse moi de partir j'y vais
j'y vais bon très bien les mailles matin
de la base ça lui allait dépêche
a aimé que jamais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui ces comptes en vefa rhône et on
attendra vous aviez oublié vos fiches
c'est ce qu'on appelle quand même une
foule impressionnante grave ah ouais tu
es dans la voiture
bah oui mais il fallait y penser avant
thierry c'est un peu dommage j'avais des
questions pas mal à quel âge est ce que
ça va c'était aussi avec son big bazar
qu'est ce qu'on fait maintenant alors
dans cette émission
ben maintenant basque assure le
conducteur alors attendez
qu'est ce qu'il ya sur le conducteur il
ya sur le conducteur que je dois dire au
revoir
oui que je dois dire au revoir aux
téléspectateurs allez-y au revoir et
téléspectateurs il ya aussi écrit il
faut pas oublier de prévenir les
spectateurs qui lie à une surprise par l
générique de fin voilà bah faites le au
revoir et téléspectateurs et n'oubliez
pas il ya une surprise après le
générique de fin
c'était pas mal non y'en a on leur fait
pas chantal non c'était très bien
tous
[Musique]
un petit instant puisque vous avez fait
votre entrée par la droite je vais vous
demander conformément aux consignes du
conseil national de surveillance de bien
vouloir faire également votre entrée par
la gauche
ça ne sera pas très long le bon
équilibre et à ce bris sortait en zigzag
je vous prie thierry pour nous avantagé
personne
voilà très bien
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
chantal c'est quoi ce bordel là ils
s'arrêtent plus l'applaudît aujourd'hui
écoutés village ont peur de sortir avec
lui c'est son boulot au départ mais
ouais d'accord
évoquant les faits rares et et
d'applaudir et s'est étiré un voilier
avec la direction de prévention et trois
semaines
1538 francs moi tant que j'ai pas mon
pognon d'accord mais je veux l'éviter
val et trois passes à chantal
développements en syrie
le corner de sa vie
[Applaudissements]
les corrections de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un pouce
bleus